well we're joined now by the man who's
got to make all those sums add up the
shadow chancellor John McDonnell thank
you for being with us this morning so
let's start by talking about your big
policy announcement today the idea of
this Robin Hood tax on financial
transactions yeah in the city now I can
see why you want to do this politically
you know Pods punish those nasty rich
bankers who caused the financial crash
but economically it's pretty risky isn't
it at a time when because of brexit
banks are threatening to move abroad to
places like Paris or Frankfurt it's not
it's not about punishing bankers or
anything like that it's simply
correcting basically well tackling a
couple of loopholes that there is an
existing system we've got had stamp duty
on shares for 300 years and individuals
trading those shares pain or point
naught 5 percent of a tax on them stamp
duty on them hasn't applied to banks and
hedge funds and others in addition to
that it hasn't applied to the
derivatives markets in terms of
basically credits and equity and it
hasn't applied to corporate bonds either
so we we're tackling a loophole here now
the issue I understand what you're
saying about the issue of does this mean
that these transactions will move
elsewhere well it's interesting because
one Europe without developing their own
financial transaction task they've done
but that has been stalled well that's
interesting at the stall that's
interesting the story that is stalled is
two years old
last October it moved dramatically
forward ten countries signed up and
they're expecting to introduce it this
year in addition to this is nothing new
this idea has been around for a long
while I've been campaigning for for over
15 years in fact Hillary Clinton
included in her democrat party manifesto
as well all we're trying to do is
correct a loophole this isn't about
punishing anyone but it is about saying
to the banks and the hedge funds that
actually where they're speculating the
most risky speculation in derivatives we
want them to make a contribution just
fair a fair country very small we're
saying no point not 2% not even the same
level as other transaction well one
person who disagrees with you on this is
Labour's magic as you know and sneaked
on we'll have a look at what Sadiq Khan
has have previously said about this
people will just go to other parts of
the world where there is no fun
mental transaction tax and he also
described the idea as madness and you
can see why because in the year to March
2016 the City of London contributed 11
percent of all tax revenue go big gamble
it is but we're talking to it we're
talking to a tiny fraction more and when
Sadiq was saying that do what at that
point in time the European system had
stalled it hasn't now it's moved on
quite swiftly so I think circumstances
have changed now is the right time to do
this is a small transactional tax we're
asking a small contribution from the
city you know that we bailed out the
city ten years ago when the crash came
we pulled hundreds of billions of pounds
into it since then a hundred billion
pounds has been given that intact in
bonuses in the city so we're asking for
a small contribution to them what to do
to fund our public services to front to
make sure our children are educated to
make sure you have a decent health
service it's not much to ask you know
let's talk a bit more about that leaked
draft manifesto because it did seem as
if this was you know complete nightmare
of fast really for the Labour Party I
wasn't very we know but was it not
though because you'd guarantee these
were free headlines for days some of
your policies are polling quite well
yeah yeah you must be quite pleased with
whoever mysterious geniuses who leaked
it oh I didn't want it leader I said it
caused a bit of panic amongst us I had
to work through the night on some of the
things to make sure we were prepared for
the Claus 5 so it definitely wasn't
anyone from the leadership team no no no
no I said yeah I know I know I don't
thinks this is a conspiracy no it wasn't
I tell you what when I heard about it I
liked him what do we do now
actually the course library to the next
day we took people through the manifesto
people are very excited few amendments
and you'll see those in the manifesto we
launched on Tuesday but generally the
spirit was pretty good but I don't know
I would rather we stuck to our plans
around this one saves panic in anyway
saves me sleepless nights yeah of course
the issue that I'm looking at here is
we've all Celia drop at the elite yeah
manifesto and I really am struggling to
see how some of these numbers okay Ann
Arbor so if you put to one side the 25
billion of borrowing for infrastructure
spending
you're still pledging at least 60
billion pounds a year I mean does that
figure time right 260 billion an extra I
don't disappoint it Sophie
wait until Tuesday we're going to set
out every for every policy the costing
of that policy and the funding source
and you'll see with I don't think any
political party has ever done this
before on any scale and in this detail
and you'll see the funding sources will
have been assessed and they'll be
derived from quite professional advice
that we've had over the time just as the
Robin Hood Tax today I devised that on
the basis of what economists were saying
what tax collectors themselves have been
saying to us and tax lawyers as well and
we're using that sort of range of
expertise to get there so it's going to
be an uphill task though to find all
this money because by my reckoning
you're about 35 billion pounds short if
you if you third by a billion pounds of
funding and sorry over extra revenue
that you've said through necktie below
from the Robin Hood Tax six billion in
contacts 20 billion from corporation tax
you're still go in an awful way short
there Sarah go now in the manifesto
you're basically saying that there's
going to be an extra tax or extra
spending you'll see on Tuesday and you
shouldn't choose what we're saying
there'll be no black holes or anything
like that there'll be a fully costed
program look compare us with the
Conservatives this morning they just
launched a housing promise which I can't
see a pound sign in the press release or
the information that they provide us
with and it's one that completely
speculative based on past performance
which has been an utter failure for the
last seven years so you'll see on
Tuesday I think right exciting policies
some of which have been leaked but
you'll see a cost of program as well and
that will be work for a week ago to do
this then so if it's not bad it's not
cost as you'll come back here it's all
you know bring me back and we'll go
through the line bye-bye
okay okay I'll hold you to that I'll be
back you sure let's talk about some of
the ideas you'll say that you're excited
about some of your manifesto commitments
but it does seem as though some of the
things that have been described as kind
of radical left-wing not necessarily so
I mean take tuition fees for example and
in many ways that's quite a regressive
policy because graduates earn around six
thousand pounds a year more than non
graduates they wash it a plumber for
example fund the education of someone
who's middle-class for a much wealthier
background I mean that was an expensive
pledge because that plumber will have a
son and daughter while still go to
university aspires to go to university
and doesn't want to come out
by debt and to be frank what we want to
do is build upon that aspiration but the
I'm the Sun hey it back when they can
currently don't they when they earn
enough to be able to think what's
interesting about this this systems
imploding we now know that half the
amount is not going to be paid back so
this system whoever's in government in
the long term would have had to adjust
and tackle this problem the predictions
are at least half the amount of money
that's lend out will not be paid that
someone has got to correct the system
and if we can correct it in a way in
which actually tuition fees are
abolished people do not get celebrate
debt in that way and at the same time
it's in full affordable for the general
taxation I think I think that's the way
forward ran to burden our young people
with debt and a system that's going to
collapse anyway you see in some ways you
could say that it's a similar story with
free school meals for example where
you're talking about universal free
school meals not means-testing again
that is an expensive giveaway then
people who can already fold it how do we
fund that we thought it was the best way
to do it was to book v80 I'm not on the
private lending I'm talking about the
decision how about where you spend the
money you have free school meals for
everyone including the very well you
have to you have my viewers are
universal benefits are the best because
everyone gets them and therefore
everyone defends them and yes to use
that phrase we're all in it together I
think is quite I think helpful for
society overall but also you do have to
say well will that be funded fairly and
we believe that all the proposals we're
putting forward costed but also fairly
funded as well as properly funded
because I do wonder you are giving
giveaways there to people who don't
necessarily need it an education is of
course a huge issue for lots of people
lots of inequalities and education
disadvantaged kids already a year behind
their peers by a stranger sighs so why
is it you're deciding to spend the money
on coffee families and actually bit the
bump and catering companies as well let
let's take the example of tuition fees
on the latest statistics the number that
the percentage from states children from
state schools has actually gone down
since in percentage terms since it went
from 3,000 to 9,000 I don't want
anything to be a disincentive in terms
of people staying on for education
higher education in particular and in
many ways if we feel
costas it the tuition fees altogether
will enable people to go to university
without that burden
we will not be dividing people up either
it will be all people wanting to have
education my view is this that education
is a gift from one generation to another
it's not a commodity to be bought and
sold did you have a round with Angela
Reina about this no I don't know where
that came from yourself no I don't know
where that came from we know we've
always worked closely together on this
and she supported of our overall
education policy of course yes she's
Brut I tell you I think Angela Reina for
me I always thought she was going to be
the nine Bevan of the Jeremy Corbyn
government because I introduced a free
education free national health service
um cradle-to-grave
she's going to introduce a national
education service from cradle to grave
so you talking about universal have
benefits here and it's interesting as
well on pensions because on pensions
you're effectively to the right of
Teresa may as well by guaranteeing the
triple arc to people who have already
done very well I was about placed on an
adventure
no noise we're not honest have done very
well if you can either it - we've got
nearly 2 million working-age we've got
nearly 2 million people in pensioners in
poverty at the moment and if we don't
invest it on and maintain the triple lot
now those young people all gone up more
than the real wages of cause they'd
waited sad nated over the last few years
in the 1980s mrs. Thatcher brought the
link between earnings and pensions as a
result of that pensioners have been
living in poverty large numbers of them
I've been campaigning for 30 years for
this when the Tories introduced the
triple lock I supported them because I
do not want are pensioners living in
poverty in addition to that I do not
want the young people today to have a
pension in the future that puts them
into poverty this is the way of
protecting it that policy has worked
because pensions are now better off than
working-age households so again I'm
asking you what is that so thing are you
choosing to Anam money on Pinole who are
doing what okay let me respond there but
people in work at the moment why they
living in why two-thirds of our children
in poverty have someone in their
household in work why is that because
wages are so low so we're tackling that
by introducing a 10 pound minimum wage
and yes restoring trade union rights at
work sort that wages can be protected
we're looking after not just pensioners
we're looking after working families as
well it isn't one or the other
also on this pensions issue the young
people today are the pensioners tomorrow
we undermine the
today they will inherit basically
poverty in the old age that's why this
is so important you see you say that
you've got this kind of radical
left-wing vision but it's hard not to
conclude that actually you're doing is
that the same as what all politicians do
at election time which is expensive buns
for people who don't necessarily need it
no we're transforming society we're
making it more equal make it radically
fairer and that's why I'm saying today
in terms of the City of London the hedge
funds and the banks we need you to pay a
bit more because we need you to invest
in we need you to invest fairly in our
society so that our children can be
educated we do not have queues waiting
up for operations in the way that we
have at the moment people on trolleys
and corridors in hospitals we're asking
everyone just to pay their fair share
now if you look at the polls it does
still seem as though the Conservatives
are going to be the ones with the keys
to number 10 Jeremy Corbyn in a recent
interview it said this about whether or
not he would stay on as leader I was
elected if Labour lose I was elected
leader of this party and I'll stay
leader of this party if Jeremy Corbyn
your closest ally in the politics gets
around the same vote shares Ed Miliband
had last time do you think he's got case
to stay on this is a darkest you don't
you don't ah look when someone's about
to start a race you don't go up to and
say I'm going to win or lose what he got
it to the end we're in the middle of
this race and we're fighting it hard
yes we've improved in the polls of this
week and I think that you'll see that in
the next few weeks itself and I will
we're in it to win all stop you see you
say that you don't ask people but of
course you ask people David Cameron for
example was asked whether or not he'd
resign or not if you ask the referendum
it's a genuine question not a
hypothetical question we're in to win
we're going to win this election we're
mobilizing now we're improving the polls
our policies every time we announce them
have huge tremendous support in this
next few weeks I think you'll see us
turning this round you see previously
you've said it would be inevitable that
he'd step down if he lost so be change
of you no not at all what I'm saying now
is when a general action campaign I
think we're going to win I think the
polls are showing that because our
policies are so promising and on the
basis of that you'll see Jeremy Corbyn
at number 10 . so you've agreed with
yourself before that it would be never
no I'm not even going there what I'm
saying is we're in the middle of
election campaign we're fighting for
everyone we know how tough it is we know
what the polls are saying
but we're turning it we're turning that
corner okay
Shadow Chancellor Jean McDonald thank
you very much for coming on the show
today